olalala s'épancher c'est vraiment
injuste
c'était ma boîte préférées oui je m'en
servais pour cacher mes trésors françois
que cela se fait je les regarde casimir
genre branoma je vais jamais vu ainsi
que lui arrive t il
mais je ne sais pas je n'ai pas osé lui
parler j'ai préféré venir te prévenir
tu as très bien fait gelé
je vais lui parler à toit ils n'auraient
sans doute pas voulu se confier
tu as raison mais tu crois qu'il va
parler à toi bien sûr d'ailleurs tu
avoir quasiment
qu est-ce qu salle c'est moi comment
était aujourd'hui des émirats mais c'est
vraiment pas la question la plus
intelligente à me poser tu vois quoi
quand je suis désespéré excuse-moi
casimir je croyais agir avec tact du
talent peu mais je me suis plus un bébé
10% avec talk avec tact
cela veut dire avec finesse habilité
et bien c'est complètement raté d'accord
et contrit n'explique mois au moins pour
que tu es aussi triste non mais que lui
mais je t'ai déjà dit non alors tu ne
veux rien dire
c'est justement mais je dis qu'on doit
vivre mais je parlerai h vie voilà c'est
tout et pourquoi julie seulement parce
que je suis triste et que j'ai besoin
d'être consolé mais quand julie me
console beaucoup mieux que toi c'est
beau je lis va voir ce qui ne va pas
avec casimir
moi je vais terminer tranquillement
mourir mais françois ne te vexe pas
lille et si malheureux il ne sait pas ce
qu'il dit ou ce qu'il veut du réseau
console de bien mais ne lui pose pas de
question précise tout de suite je vais
essayer alors casimir tu es vraiment si
malheureux que ça oui mon oncle
archibald m'a demandé de lui renvoyer la
jolie boîte avec la serrure rouge
c'était ma boîte préférées enfin il me
l'avait pas prêter il me l'avait donné
tu t'es peut-être trompé kazim est le
cadeau c'était le petit chat qui était
dans la boîte
la boîte ne servant qu'à le transporter
100 fait rien c'est quand même injuste
mon pauvre casimir tu lui as lui a
renvoyé la boîte mais oui tout de suite
j'ai été obligé parce que tu sais mon
nom car archi barré est très sévère et
que les rôles j'ai tout entendu
quasiment
et je suis vraiment navré pour toi veux
tu que nous fassions vêtue que nous
jouions au jeu des mimes pour changer
les idées non il y avait dû faire une
course en sac
non j'ai pas envie une danse non non je
suis trop con désespérant or mon pauvre
casimir
bonjour tout le monde un bouchon
chauffeur on vous savez casimir est très
triste parce que son oncle archi cas
limite d'ailleurs sept cargos des
seynois par bkc rouges ont choisi mais
attention pour sûr tendant par six
balles a mis un nouveau cadeau de dans
un nouvel animal je crois bien que
toutes les explications sont sur cette
cassette dans cette enveloppe qu'il
fallait recueillir
j'ai marché le plus vite et plus loin je
les avais cherché pour lecteur de
cassettes six coups mais alors vous vous
appelez les enfants attendus
si vous aimez c'est d'ailleurs je peux
prendre la boîte non non non non ce
monsieur je m'amuse beaucoup et je ferai
comme la dernière fois je vais rester
pour tenir la boîte si vous ne voyez pas
d'inconvénient françois un pas du tout
facteur vous rentrez alors on commence
j'agis je suis prête à kaboul a annoncé
le quasi mais c'est moi comme tu m'avais
envoyé une très gentille lettre pour me
remercier du petit charles où j'ai
décidé de faire un nouveau cadeau
as tu connais le principe du jeu à
chaque numéro de la série correspond la
présentation d'un des dix heures c'est
ça il faudrait trouver le bon numéro
pour ouvrir la boîte
fabienne attention tu dors à le croire
ça ne va pas être facile hein
heureusement tous les enfants sont là
haut ils vous chez vous vous aider
casimiro cia allons-y
je suis très grande et jeu court très
vite je porte de très belles plumes je
suis gourmande mais heureusement je
l'estomac très solide
je vise en afrique sur la serrure rouge
j'ai lu numéro quel est cet animal
développement qua non il ne touche en
catherine wade ne trouve c'est une autre
vie
vous croyez l'autre animal julie je le
trouve très beau je suis certain le
véritable roi de la basse cour
je suis orgueilleux et batailleur mais
mon rôle le plus important est de servir
de réveil matin sur la serrure rouge g
le numéro 2 qui a donné tout le monde
tout le monde d'accord aussi à tous ces
facteurs de répondre pour un parc lecoq
à moi que deviner que c'était un contre
le révélateur travailler sur la piste
j'ai dit s'il te plaît à l'autre je suis
un mammifère mais je vis dans la mer on
dit que je suis le plus intelligent des
animaux j'aime beaucoup m'amuser
surtout avec les hommes je sais faire
pleins d'acrobaties sur la serrure rouge
g le numéro 3 alors qu'elles n'ont
aucune idée cadeau femme qui habite à un
dauphin sa nouvelle cote comme dans la
chanson à quoi on reconnaît qu'ils sont
de vrais un autre humain parce que j'ai
deux longues oreilles
j'aime beaucoup les carottes je suis
très gentil mais aussi très heureux car
je n'ai rien vous défendre sur la
serrure rouge
si le numéro 4 l'explication mois pour
que nos petits amis puissent aider
casimiro 6-1 alors mais c'est fini à
l'explication
même si notre maison à notre place je ne
comprends pas pourquoi ils toujours du
mal de moi on me traite de bandes
blanches et noires
je suis beaucoup plus joli que les
autres et que les poux sur la serrure
rouge
j'ai les numéros 5 j'avais dit annie
rooney avait alors fait chemin qu'est ce
qui permit sur la passe que la people la
ville est moins souvent leurs ouailles
j'aurais pu y penser oui tout ce qui
brille elle le prend l emporter dans son
immense variété non non c'est au psg les
tripes je vis en amérique du nord
je suis beaucoup plus gros que ma
cousine la vache qui vit en europe j'ai
toujours la tête baissée avec du poil
brun et frisés dessus avant nous vivions
très nombreux avec les indiens et depuis
l'arrivée des hommes blancs mais pareil
ont presque tous été massacrés sur
l'acer rouge g le numéro 6 à nouveau
hélas c'est un bilan un paysan
et on n'a pas vu au zoo casimir je crois
que nous avons tout écouter ouais tu as
une idée
moi j'ai trouvé dans la boîte c'est un
bison les onze est d'accord enfin non
pourquoi parce qu'elle est trop petit et
oui c'est bien sûr l otan d autres idées
car si c'est pas un bison c'est une
autre lui chat et l'autruche qui ça à
votre avis pourquoi repartant petit vous
avez la grandeur de la boîte
qu'est ce qui reste alors quels sont les
animaux qui pourraient rentrer dans
cette boîte quoi la pilule à coke à
lapentti que choisissait la table
l'attendent
parce que bien des gerbes qui dépasse
moi je choisis aussi le latin toujours à
part moi ils sont issus surtout
maintenant et je pense que vous avez
raison pour bons numéros 4 numéros car
je met en jeu mais à la voir
oui c'est bien il a un peu peur après
son grand voyage